[Music]
chuck we're back
yes so do you do you like these
explainer videos or is it a chore for
you
no um uh you know what i like
because i know you're on payroll and
everything you know so but no so you
show up
because we asked you to tell the truth i
mean
you we could sit here and watch paint
dry if i'm getting paid i love it
no uh no the truth is what i like is
when i think
like that they're going to suck
and then there's something really i
never thought about before
so if that's happening if i know but if
it's happening to me then i'm like it's
got to be happening to other people
okay i'm like this is such a
banal subject how could there be
anything
truly interesting in this but then
when you pull something out of it that's
like a little plot twist or something
then i'm like yo that was that was
really cool oh okay so i like this is
plot twist i like that analogy okay so
here we go
today i'm gonna talk about the greek
alphabet uh well then you messed it all
up again
after i give you a glowing
accolades you turn around and you hit me
with the greek alphabet
number one i don't know that's number
one all right no okay but
look i know it so we're good here all
right okay and number two
it's an alphabet so all right that's so
that's all you know about it you don't
know it and you know it's an alphabet
we're good and how you gonna make that
exciting is my point like we're gonna
start there
okay so that's we're pledging a
fraternity a couple of things i want to
point out okay the alphabet we use is is
called the roman alphabet a b c d e f g
okay um what's interesting about the
greek alphabet
is that every one of its letters
are commonly spelled
okay so its first letter in the greek
alphabet is alpha
spell alpha right a a-l-p-h-a
okay first letter of the roman alphabet
is a spell a
a
all right let me give you okay spell h
uh h h
h see there's no you we can't we don't
know how to wrap our head around the
question
of what it is to spell our letters
whereas the greek alphabet are fully
spellable from beginning to end
alpha beta right okay i'll tell you how
to spell h
it's a-i-t-c-h
h yes that that does spell h there's
only one way that can come off your
tongue and that's h
that's the official way to spell
h-a-i-t-c-h now we do some spelling of
our alphabet
when you buy a t-shirt you can just use
the letter t
dash shirt or else you can write it how
t-e-e
that is how you spell the letter t right
you know people aren't just being cute
that's how you spell the letter
right and like z is z-e-e z-e
okay so but you hardly ever see that
it's so that's an interesting spell
m e-m actually m
oh sorry
em that makes sense yeah okay uh and so
so you so it's an interesting feature of
the alphabet
all right just wanna put that out there
second
um the the first letter we all know is
what
alpha and the last letter omega omega
alpha to omega and so this was
uh uplifted into christianity correct uh
alpha to omega you see it on some
religious shrines right because it's
it's a wonderful thing i am the
beginning in the end
and the beginning and the end exactly
and of course the
the new testament the christian bible is
written in in
um in greek so that's it's not a stretch
to
then use the alpha and the omega in that
way okay
all right so let's go through the
alphabet in sequence okay
alpha uh first letter next letter is
beta
and we've we've heard this word before
beta testing of software
exactly right you've heard that i don't
know that people are thinking greek
letter in the alphabet
but uh beta testing is the testing where
it's not ready for prime time yet
it could still have bugs you get experts
to play with it they can find the errors
you fix it
and then you release it okay so you can
be alpha tester beta tester and by the
time you're done
it's out there and you're no longer
saying alpha or beta okay um
third greek letter is i don't know i'm
gonna go with
gamma lambda gamma very nice gamma alpha
beta gamma
alpha beta and gamma were the words
given
to high energy particles in the early
days of particle physics
before we knew what the things were that
we're carrying these energies
so there's a particle which happened to
be the nucleus of a helium atom
but it had an energetics that we were
trying to measure and we could always
repeat it and the nucleus of the helium
is called the alpha particle
wow that's a little weird right the
nucleus of a helium atom the alpha
particle
okay the electron is called the beta
particle
and actual gamma ray radiations are
called gamma rays
so alpha beta gamma these were three
highly energetic things that
started popping out of nuclei as we
started splitting atoms
and analyzing radioactivity this is 100
130 120 30 years ago
so in physics alpha beta gamma are are
energy levels in particle physics
right two of them correspond with
particles the gamma rays corresponds
with just
energy and of course the hulk knows all
about gamma rays yes
exactly and but don't ask him about it
when he's angry
you don't like him you won't like
somebody's angry
okay i saw this meme
called the the credible hulk have you
ever seen that
no the crowd um i
i need evidence uh i need
i need peer-reviewed studies i it's
called the credible hulk incredible
you won't like me when i'm angry i need
this evidence
it's really good i need that all right
so let's keep going uh alpha beta gamma
next delta right the capital delta is a
triangle
just a simple triangle and we call
things that look like those triangles
deltas
like the river delta at the bottom of
the mississippi it sprays out from the
mouth of the mississippi
and opens up into a fan shape and that's
called a delta
delta right all right and delta is also
in math
the the difference between two
quantities
it's called the delta the change in
that's exactly right uh alpha beta gamma
delta uh epsilon you don't see much of
that next one is
um zeta and ada you don't see much of
that eta
either next one is theta theta
is a is a circle with a line through the
middle and
in math you use that to represent the
angle uh you see that a lot in
geometry so chuck after theta we have
iota
iota and iota is like a tiny little eye
you write it and you might miss it if
you're not looking careful enough
and how do we use iota it's actually an
english word i will
not give in not one iota that you're
saying
not even i don't know one iota iota
all right right so it's we it's up
taking up took
into our english language the iota i
love it
okay after that you have the word kappa
okay
now kappa is a common letter that shows
up in fraternities and sororities
and alpha psi indicate for example and
i like kappa because it gives
funny meaning to say hey what
so what fraternity do you belong to is
it oh it's called i tap a keg
you're kidding me i tap a k
go which one is that oh it's over there
with the kegs out front so
it's a way to just have fun with the uh
the greek sounding letters of
fraternities and sororities after that
we get to
lambda i always like to be in the d
consecutive lamb but uh lambda
is the symbol we use in math and in
physics to refer to
wavelength of light and the length
uh yeah i hadn't thought about it that
way thank you it's an upside down y if
you flip it over to be a regular y
so lambda and it's the the phonetics of
the
lambda with length wavelength and that's
why that letter was chosen
to refer to the wavelength of light it's
just the curve
line and you go from crest to crest okay
and you measure that that's the
wavelength
all right and all light has a wavelength
associated with it different colors
have different wavelengths okay
some are longer some are shorter so
that's a lambda
and then we get mu new
c sometimes i say psi mu and
we don't use those much at all so we'll
go right on passes
okay yeah it depends on i think
i've heard greek people pronounce many
of these greek letters differently from
how i learned it in my math class
and i want to defer to them but i'm not
really because
pi they'll call it p no i'm not calling
it p i'm calling it pi
all right we're gonna have to draw the
longer we have to draw the line at p we
haven't gotten a pie yet that's coming
up
okay so the next one is omicron omicron
oh my god perseus five
give me some star trek uh what was that
star trek yeah
yeah yeah so omicron what i like about
that is if you separate them
you have an o and what's the word that
follows it
ecron i don't know micron micron
o micron okay so in a way
that's little o sweet so just think just
think about this little o let's just
start just just stay with me on that
okay
micron that's where we get the prefix
micro
okay microscope you use it to see
little things so that's this
is weird the greatest alphabet the greek
alphabet is totally it's all in
to this it's all in okay so we'll get
back to
o micron in a bit next up letter it's
alpha beta gamma delta epsilon zeta
eight of theta eau de
captain lander nukes i omicron pie
is next for perimeter that's the
phonetics
and the perimeter of a circle you can
get that invoking the constant pi
and march 14th is pi day uh all over
uh the world if you keep your calendar
as the month preceding the day
three 3.14
is the first three digits of pi and that
gets you pretty far even though they're
many many more digits
so uh pi is the if you take this
circumference the perimeter of a
perimeter of a circle divide by its
diameter right
then you've got the number pi
and and that's no matter the size of the
structure not the size of the circle
yeah because the once one gets bigger
the other gets bigger you divide out
pi shows up very important a constant
not only in math but in the entire
universe
okay so what's next uh i get rho sigma
tau
upsilon phi okay there it is
uh next is uh chi or sometimes chai
c-h-i that's a wonderful tea
yeah the greeks were making tea before
then no i think they were drinking
something else i think
the tea was from the far east i bet no
chinese
it's the chi and then you have psi
psi psi and like new age people
sometimes talk about psy energy but i
think it's that's not for the greek
alphabet i think i'd have to double
check this
that they're really referencing uh its
psychic energy psi
energy psychic energy okay well you have
sort of an energy field so they
got a hold of that one and i got uh
omega
the 26th and last letter of the greek
alphabet
now where we left off i left off
i said put a pin in omicron
oh micron oh well the last letter of the
alphabet is o
mega so in the greek alphabet we have o
micron and o mega mega
okay so mega not mega mega so mega
uh you have megaphones right right big
yeah but before we had uber
uber big uber this before uber became a
company
it was uber this as big and and and good
and
extra amounts of what it is but then
before that we had mega
this is mega big i had a mega good time
so all i'm just saying we have a little
o micron and a big o
o mega and so just it's the interesting
sort of etymologies of these words as
you come through and plus
capital omega looks like a horse's hoof
yes okay a horseshoe i love it it's my
favorite
capital letter of them all on both
languages anyhow
in math we tapped so many of these
letters and calculus especially
to represent what it is we're talking
about because you run out of letters
using just the
roman alphabet so i want to thank the
greeks for being early
in on this and they have really cool
squiggly letters
and you can spell them all and i want to
thank the greeks
for showing me some of the best parties
i've ever been to in my life in college
amazing okay that was the itapa keg
fraternity you got it right chuck that
was it just a little excursion
on the alphabet i liked it and i only
became fluent when i started doing math
and i said let me get to the bottom of
all these squiggly letters that
we're drawing here and so there you have
it we got to call it quits there this
has been star talk explainer
the greek alphabet astrophysics edition
i'm neil degrasse tyson keep looking up
[Music]